[Music]
All right. So, what we are going to do
is I'll quickly go through u couple of
demos. That's all. That's that's that's
the plan. Uh so stand is an open-source
SDK uh which has only one motivation is
to make your agents as simple as
possible without any scaffolding. The
only thing that is needed is tool and
the model.
That's all. There is no scaffolding. You
don't have to dictate or what the agent
should do. And the idea is
since the models are becoming more and
more intelligent, we want the model to
take uh the reasoning part of our
agents. We don't want to scaffold with
lot of prompts, lot of uh system
prompts, a lot of backgrounds and all
that. So that's that's that's all to it.
And it is also integrated with uh
various uh
third party providers like Langfuse
u light lm. You can use any model of
your choice. You don't need to use
bedrock hosted models but you can go
ahead with any of the model of your
choice using light lm and also you can
use lama if you want to test it out
locally.
Now this is the agentic loop that we
have in strands as I mentioned it's just
the models and the tools that's all and
that is actually the two strands in this
logo of strand denotes one is for model
one is for tool I just happened to know
this yesterday so yeah okay so now let's
see a demo how how you can create
a strand agent so the demo that we are
going to have now it's Very simple. We
are going to read one file from our disk
and then we will generate a summary of
that. Then we will write that summary
into our uh local drive and then we will
also tell the agent to speak out the
result. So basically we are trying to
add the voice aspect of this. Okay. So
now there are three things we are doing
reading a file, writing a file and
generating a speak uh speech. All of
these three we are doing it using the
default tools from strands. So you don't
have to write any custom tool for this.
You just have to install uh strands tool
and boom you can get started with this.
Okay. So just remember this uh use case.
Uh I have recorded this because I heard
that the Wi-Fi is pretty fantastic here.
So
uh all right. So let's see how how it
goes.
So here uh the first thing we we need to
do is we need to install strands. So
that is what we are doing here.
Uh we are just installing the strands
agent and then we are going to install
strand tools. So this is simple pip
install. Nothing fancy here. And when
you install the strands tool it gives
you a lot of default tools. You can
always make your own custom tools. uh
but uh this is how you can create uh or
use out of the box tools. So these are
the three tools that we are going to
use. Now we are going to write the
application.
So the first thing that we need to do is
we need to import strands. And by
default it uses bedrock model which is
uh cloud 3.7 under the hood. But if you
don't want to use that, you can always
use any model of your choice. But by
default, it uses bedrock. I'm trying to
show you how you can define the model.
But later on when we create agents, you
will see that you don't have to give
model ID by default only it should work.
But I just wanted to show you if you
want to define your own model how you
can define uh the model. Uh in in case
you want, you can use Olama there. And
now this is a system prompt. when I
share the GitHub repo try to do this
delete the system prompt it should still
work but I just want to wanted to give
you an intuition of how things work
under the hood and if you see here all
we are doing here we are giving the
model ID system prompt and the tools
that's all and now we are asking the
same question that read this uh chapter
number 10 uh summarize that and uh write
it in a markdown file and speak out now
to
listen to the speech let me increase the
volume. So now it is reading the file.
Then it is trying to write the file
after creating the summary and now it
should speak out. The human eye
functions like a camera with light
entering through the cornea. So you get
the idea right? So how these things
work. Now there is one more uh demo I
have which is around MCP with strands
because without MCP and agents I was
told that you cannot have any talk in
this conference. So all right. How many
of you have heard of um
three blue one brown YouTube channel? Oh
wow. So you know what we are talking
about. So we are trying to build
animations and videos like what we see
in three blue one brown. It is powered
by one of the library called manim. So
I've been working with this manim for a
couple of years. uh to uh if you are
from uh science and mathematics
background on value uh uh you know on
vectors SVD these are the concepts which
are very easily we can explain uh using
visualization. So what we are going to
do now is we are going to create a
strands agent
using
an MCP server which will help me to
generate these videos using manim
with me so far? Yeah. So this is how we
can do. Assume that we already have an
MCP server which can generate this
video. Okay. Just assume that it is not
here but it it is uh uh already there.
Okay. So
so now what we are going to do is using
strands we are just going to
call the MCP client and make use of that
server. So in this case I'm importing
the stance agent and the MCP client.
The next thing that we are going to do
is we are going to create the MCP
client. And if you see here
the this is my
MCP server path where I have written the
code to execute that MC uh manim uh
code. So that this particular code I'm
not showing but after this I will show
it to you what uh that code is doing.
But that's all. I don't have to do
anything else. Now when I create an
agent in the previous example, if you if
you remember, we mentioned that
agent then tools equal to read file,
write file and speak. In this case, I'm
not using any of the default tools. My
tool is nothing but the MCP server. And
for that, I'm just using tools equal to
manm client list tool sync. So this will
this will broadcast all the tools that
the MCP server has to my client. So that
is nothing but the stance agent with me
so far? Yes. Perfect. And at the end we
are just going to give the prompt. So in
this case you can give any prompt of
your choice. But here we are just saying
that create a a visualization for this
cubic equation within the range of xus 3
to x= 3. If you want to try this with
something else, you can always give like
u explain me bite pair encoding uh in a
visual way or you can say uh explain SVD
explain how two uh two metrics of 2x 2
+2 u you know perform a matrix
multiplication or whatever right
so now let's see this so for this before
I start the MCP client or the strand
agent I have to make sure that server is
up and running right so in Here I'm just
making the MCP server up so so that this
is available in that uh local host and
now I'm running this app. py which
contains the code which we have seen a
while back.
So finally we can just give the prompt.
So this is the same prompt that we have
seen in the previous slide and let's see
what it generates.
And if you notice, we have not mentioned
any um uh any scaffolding kind of a like
system prompt and all that. We want the
model to reason about this and figure it
out of its own.
So I have not done anything. This is and
it is not photoshopped. It just came up
like that.
And you can actually define the duration
of the video let's say 30 seconds 10
seconds and all that
and if you have worked in manm to
generate this code it takes some time
right so it's not that straightforward
okay so that's about the integration
with uh MCP and strand and
before I show you a few of the resources
let me show you the code.
No one sp me while I am working but
everybody pings when
Okay.
All right. So this is the
So this is the MCP server that I have.
It just I have some I have imported u
fast MCP and
This is the this is couple of couple of
the um tools that I have defined. And if
you see this here, the way that you can
create an MCP tool is just wrap it
around with an MCP. Decorator, right? So
this becomes these two are the tools for
my MCP server. And when I come here,
not this one. when I come here and if
you look at the main function so this is
the function where I'm going to call
that using strands agent and MCP client
right uh so I what I've shown in the
presentation is just few lines from this
main function but we are doing little
bit more uh before act uh before just
calling uh the agent we are listing the
tools but before that
uh we are also giving some examples And
if I show you this example,
I'm just giving one example of how to
create uh you know uh and and uh and
construct in using manim. That's all you
can think of it like u one short
prompting. It's like that. Uh but my as
far as the agent is concerned is just
one line of code. uh you know we just
list the tools and then here we are just
calling the agents that's all and then
we have a while true loop so that we get
an interactive u chat kind of an
experience okay and
in our first uh demo
um not first demo I want to show you one
quick thing is uh how you can create a
custom uh tool okay this is I'm just
jumping around a couple of things
because we just have 2 3 minutes. It's
it it's no less than a time bomb. Trust
me when I see this. Right. So
let's say you have any function. Okay.
Uh let me just quickly
scroll down and show it to you.
Yeah. So if you have any function and
you want to create that function uh you
know turn that function into a tool all
you have to do is this uh
where is that? Yeah, all you let's say
this is a function. Yeah, there's a
different example. It's there in the
GitHub, but I will not explain that. But
the idea is let's say you have a
function, you want to convert that into
a tool. All you have to do is just
import uh tools from here and decorate
it with tools. Once that is done, this
retrieve from quadrant will become
a tool for you. So next time when you
create an agent
when you create an agent you just give
that as a tool and now here in this list
of tools you can give your custom tool
as well as your default tools whatever
we have read file write file speak and
so on and so forth. Okay so that's
that's about it. Now if you want to
learn more about strands
uh we have a GitHub repository. So this
is the launch blog. Um this is the
documentation which is nothing but
strandsagent.com
and this is the GitHub link. Okay. And
if you have any questions uh feel free
to uh uh you know ask me. I I'll be
around and we have a booth inside as
well. Uh there are plenty of demos with
uh strands with lambda mcp and uh you
know to get started. This is an open
source project. Feel free to raise a PR
if you have something if you have built
something into the samples code
repository within stance uh GitHub and
uh yeah uh share what you build and uh
if you have any feedback let us know.
Thank you so much.
[Music]